achten sie wollen sich jetzt beschweren über
die Polizei wenn es geht und wenn es geht
nicht direkt bei der Polizei ihn wäre also
eine unabhängige Kontrollbehörde lieber ja
so mit tausend Angestellten ja die den
ganzen Tag Beschwerden der Bevölkerung
über die Polizei nachgeht so wie das der un-
Menschenrechtsausschuss fordert genau das ist
super ja in England und die die Bundesregierung
arbeitet aber dran ja da ist ein Planung ein
unabhängiger polizeibeauftragter mit sieben
Mitarbeitern immerhin gut und diese sieben
Mitarbeiter die kümmern sich dann um wenn es nach
der FDP geht nach den Beschwerden der Polizei
aha und wo gehen Sie jetzt hin nach England aha
jetzt jetzt gehen sie ja jetzt gehen sie das
war's mit der ausgewogenen Sendung ja verstehe ah
so hier Polizei Gewalt gegen Polizei gibt's nicht
ja Clan Kriminalität gibt's nicht wahrscheinlich
gab es auch keine keine Krawalle in der silvestern
in Neukölln weil Leute wie sie die Augen
verschließen gegen das was was da los ist
in solchen Vierteln wie Neukölln so war kann
ich auch beweisen ich habe da ein paar sehr
sehr interessante Zahlen was da was da los war in
Neukölln was da an täglichen Angriffen das waren
vier die meisten Angriffe
die Waren in Berlin-Mitte
[Musik] das ist ja das Brandenburger Tor der
wohnt ja gar keine das ist ja Regierungsviertel
wieso denn damit Stimmung machen nee das hier du
filmst ja schon wieder ich habe ich habe vorhin
gesagt hier gibt's nicht zu viel mehr das waren
ganz klar ein ganz privater Moment ja weg ja
eine gute Idee ist unangemelden irgendeiner Tür in
Neukölln zu klingeln um sich
für die nach den Gründen für
Clan Kriminalität zu erkundigen natürlich
nicht deswegen mache ich das auch nicht ich
ja und und und und und wo soll ich da jetzt
klingeln na bei Clan ich Klingel mal hier nicht
hallo hallo sie kennen mich wenn ich Typen wie
sie kennen würde müsste ich nicht hier wohnen
ich bin Friedrich sind sie integriert ich wohne
schon sehr lange hier das war gar nicht ich wohne
hier nicht und bin integriert wollen sie von mir
der Friedrich also der Herr März der möchte sich
gerne also der möchte quasi die ökonomischen
und sozialen Gründe für das Entstehen von
sogenannten problemenvierteln wie hier was
ich vor Ort analysieren ich komme mal runter
er kommt mal runter
warum steht da nirgendwo CDU
vielleicht hat das jemand sauber gemacht
ah hallo Herr Klein wo sind die
Paschas haben sie wo irgendwo
kleine Paschas versteckt bitte ernst
möchte sich erkundigen ob sie denn
eventuell Kinder haben also habe ich nicht
wissen Sie bei pershas denk ich ja immer an
selbstherrliche egoistische Männer die keine
Kritik vertragen alles besser wissen und Denken
von Natur aus über Frauen zu stehen er sagte hat
keine Kinder das habe ich verstanden das habe ich
verstanden ihre Frau weigert sich also hartnäckig
zukünftige Steuerzahler zu Produkten zu fertigen
ich habe keine Frau aha er hat keine Frau ich
glaube wir nähern uns hier dem Kasus knacksus
dann sind sie also anders sie sind vom Ufer her
sind sie wegen der entsprechende Frauen ja aber
ich habe in meinem Viertel keine gefunden und
ich darf ja die Stadt nicht verlassen jetzt
interessant und wenn sie denn an die richtige Frau
finden werden Sie dann in den Hafen der Ehe segeln
ich darf ja nicht heiraten kriegt ja auch
keinen Pass das ist Berlin wir sind ganz
nah dran sind wir das ja wenn Sie also
keine Frau haben nicht war dann stürzen
sie sich also von morgens bis abends in die
Arbeit darf ja nicht arbeiten ich wusste es
das wusste ja ich habe nicht den blassen schimm
sie sind an offensichtlich Opfer eines Clans der
sie zu einem seltsamen Leben verdammt nicht
wahr und in die Hände der Kriminalität treibt
verraten sie mir den Namen dieses Clans
der in dieses unwürdige Leben aufzwingt
kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor sehen Sie die
Behörden die können ihm verbieten zu heiraten
oder zu arbeiten oder zu reisen weil er eben nur
eine Duldung hat und sozusagen seine Identität
nicht geklärt ist ja März ich weiß wer ich bin ja
ich bin ja so in meiner Eltern das waren leider
Staatenlose geflüchtete aus dem Libanon aber
diese Staatenlosigkeit wurde sozusagen vererbt
dann hätte er die Erbschaft im Ausschlag müssen
das geht nicht das sind diese sogenannten das
war jetzt zehn Jahre und jungspolitik jetzt werden
sie mal nicht Partei politisch dann hätte er eben
etwas anderes wählen müssen darf ja nicht wählen
ich kann mich dafür dass sie kein Deutscher sind
warum sind sie nicht wenigstens Ukrainer es
mag ja sein dass die Union da vielleicht eine
gewisse Mitverantwortung aber jetzt sind
wir ja in der Opposition und treiben die
Regierung vor uns her und schon gibt es ein
neues Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz ich war das
kettendungen beendet aber die CDU hat das bis zum
Ende bekämpft oder nicht wie viele geduldete gibt
es eigentlich in Deutschland ja so 250.000 und
wie viele werden von diesem Gesetz profitieren
vielleicht 30.000 so Herrschaften wem gehört
denn von ihnen der Privatflieger dahinten nein
das ist eine Diamond d62 das ist mir total egal
sie können nicht einfach im Stadtpark landen
offensichtlich bitte das war eine
angedeutete Kopfnuss was ja das
ist Widerstand gegen eine Vollstreckungsverfahren
in diesem Land
dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug